hey everybody welcome back to led live
we've got an awesome show today i
know you're gonna be blessed and have
you ever been through anything tragic
that you've wondered can god truly
turn something good out of a tragedy
find out on this episode of
led live
[Music]
light exposing darkness you guys are
awesome for tuning in today
and uh we want to thank you guys so much
for uh
checking out this video and watching our
ministry if you're new here
we hope that you'll stick around we've
got a lot of content
uh that is tackling a wide variety of
subjects but
today we're going to talk about
something that is kind of a sensitive
topic
and something that is very hard for uh
some people especially if you've
experienced a terrible terrible tragedy
in your life but
this is a beautiful story about how god
can transform
something and turn it for his glory his
good
and so i want to welcome you guys john
and jeanette
as you guys will hear a little bit of
your testimony
of how and why they even have gotten
together
this is your mother a biological mother
and when did you meet her
i met her about six weeks ago six weeks
ago
okay so you guys are going to want to
unpack this story
a little bit for us because um you know
i can only imagine meeting your
biological parent for the first time
and the emotions and everything that
goes along with that
i'm really excited to hear you guys
testimony
[Music]
so
when i saw this video that you guys had
been working on
and uh it was your testimony and and the
way that it was added together and
everything i was eating my lunch
um i think when it got sent to me and
i'll tell you man you guys pulled some
major tears out of my eyes
and i was like sitting there kind of
like crying and my co-workers were
probably like what's wrong with this guy
i saw it too in my car and i was like
man i was just crying too the whole time
it was just
it's amazing you know i think me and
john cried the most though
i don't know i tried i cry every time i
look at it yeah
every time i think about it it's very
emotional and when i get to share the
story with just a stranger
i get emotional at that moment too so
let's let's dive right into this because
i know you're going to need some time
here to develop
what what what went on so start way back
in into sort of the beginning
um of your guys's journey um i don't
know
who wants to kind of share first but
i'll start okay yeah i'll start not
ladies first but
go ahead you explain it better i i i
think i'll start because i didn't know
the whole story i was adopted when i was
a baby
and i grew up in a beautiful home
lots of love my parents were christian
deeply committed to
god and they taught my sister and i that
serving god
and humanity is is our highest calling
and so
that was a really valuable gift they
gave us and so
um i ended up becoming a pastor and
traveling the world preaching the gospel
i've seen thousands
of people give their lives to jesus
christ and uh
wait on his promise to return one day
and
uh 42 countries wow six continents
wow and and so saying all that to say
that was it was just a beautiful journey
for me of course i had some
trauma and tragedies in my life but i
was protected from things that
um could have destroyed me but and so
but in all of that though i i carried
this um
this really insatiable curiosity and
it's hard to explain but when you're
adopted
no matter how much love you have in your
life you still want to know
and and maybe there are some people that
disagree with that but i'm pretty sure
that that's
every person i know that's adopted
that's the case and i wanted to know now
when you were
younger i'm assuming you found out when
you were younger how old were you and
how did that come about
i was about six years old and it wasn't
as formal as you might think
my cousins were playing uh we have a
very big family
my mom had 12 brothers and sisters they
all just about lived in the same area
we get together my grandmother's house
every sunday and holidays and so
one of those gatherings we were all
together my cousins were playing double
dutch jump rope
where you used the two ropes and i was
teasing them grabbing the rope and one
of my older cousins this is how i
remember it my mom says it didn't happen
that's what this however
she said that's why you're adopted so i
ran in the house
in front of everybody i said mom am i
adopted
and my mom's like well yeah and i said
so doesn't mean you're not my mom i
don't have to listen to you
so i was a mischievous kid and so they
we had to talk later on they shared
as i got older the non-identified
information about my biological family
it was a closed adoption so all i had
was questions i had very
little uh information information very
few details just enough to say
don't eat this because you might die
because this is what killed your mom you
know
in terms of allergies and things like
that medical information
but i i guess i wanted to point out
that i carried that for 38 years this
this sense of
well was i not good enough what was it
and some adoptees when they're adopted
they rebel as a as a way to deal with
being adopted some
become people pleasers i think that's
even more dangerous because
then your identity is tied into what
other people think
and unfortunately that's kind of how i
was it was it's a good thing i was a
preacher
because but but it was a bad thing if i
had a church that didn't care for me and
right because then i felt like
my mistakes were my identity and it was
hard for me to separate i felt
very differently about rejection than
someone who may not have
been adopted and i carried that for 38
years
and even with all the love i got love
from teachers and camp counselors and my
parents and siblings and cousins
and church members but saying that to
say
uh i didn't know my full story and so
yeah
and so it's just in the back of your
mind constantly you know you probably
you know have that odd thought on your
head a lot in your earlier life
so what what made you eventually want to
say you know what i feel like i want to
know i want to know the truth like
about where i came from and you know
what happened how did that all come
about well i had a few false starts
so maybe in my early 20s i um
set out and contacted the adoption
agency on my information
pack and i and and it was a closed
adoption so there wasn't very far to go
then you could make an appeal to the
state and open the record and i
went down oh that's too expensive and
and i realized maybe as i look back
it's i just wasn't ready i i these false
starts
i just really wasn't truly ready maybe
because i was afraid i'd be rejected
and when you carry that sense of
rejection not knowing where you came
from
you kind of set yourself up for failure
it's like a self-fulfilling prophecy
live won't work out anywhere
that's that that's something i haven't
really thought about before you know
what i mean like the idea of
what if you go and seek out who your
biological parent is and they don't want
anything to do with you is that
is that going to send your thoughts
deeper into your
pervasive yeah yeah i i i heard
beautiful stories about adoption
reunions and i would cry and
you know my my family would notice i
turned the channel really quick if one
of these shows came up because i just
didn't want to deal with it but
i um i think there's this this pervasive
thought i did hear horror stories too
like i gave you up don't contact me ever
again so i was like
i don't know if i want to deal with that
i think either way though you get some
kind of
closure right because even like a bad
breakup you want
just tell me you'll never be with me
again so i can get all of my life
right yeah and i think i
i got to that place about a year ago i
i was living in australia and a very
good friend of mine
uh encouraged me he's like man you know
what don't you want to know where you
came from and i was like well i do but
i'm busy
i've got so much going on i can do it
and he just kind of pushed and pushed
and pushed and sometimes you know it's
good to have a crazy friend
right it loves you so much that they
want to support you forward you know
and um he he was that and so i i did
i ordered the test but i held on to her
for about a year dna test when he's at
home kids
and then when i finally took it and i
got the results i thought
it was a lot simpler than it is i
thought it would say this is your mother
and your father and this
all the way back to adam this way right
right right not not exactly like that so
it kind of shows my
ignorance right there right right and uh
with that being said
we i did have a very closely related
cousin
and um and i reached out and basically
they blocked
me like i don't really want to have
anything to do with you don't contact me
and so there it kind of sparked that
sense of oh man this is exactly
and i kind of said that to someone i was
like this is exactly why i didn't want
to do this yeah i knew it was going to
happen
and um so i let it go then a global
pandemic kit
all right and you start painting walls
that needed to be painted
right planting flowers that needed to be
planted in my case it wasn't walls or
flowers it was like
let me go back to this dna stuff yeah
and uh so i went back to it and i
actually had a message
from a very closely related cousin and
uh he said hey i'm in illinois i see
you're in michigan
i'd be happy to connect if you're
interested if not no worries
and i'm like yo this is awesome like it
just happened organically
like that person hit you he reached out
to me yeah and this is a relative
through
your mother this is a biological
relative through my mother okay
yeah i didn't know how the connection
was but i did know
that my biological family was caucasian
white right i knew that my mother's
blonde hair blue eyes these are the
scriptures that i had
yeah and so you know i remember as a kid
i'd be in the grocery store
like that could be her oh my god yeah i
mean what that would do to your mind
like walking around
yeah sure and my family was open about
you know my sister she was like oh you
were the cute
cutest puppy in the humane society you
know
it wasn't and we had so much love man i
just i have to share
the rejection part because i think
sometimes as christians
and i'm guilty of it we act as though
when we come to christ
that our pain disappears it does
dissipate
but it doesn't disappear and he he heals
us and everyone knows that a healing
process is not instant that's right but
forgiveness is
and and that's the beautiful thing but
and so
um i said sure let's do it so we got
together became really good friends
we hung out we talked and he was like
man you know you should find your birth
mother and
he didn't know his birth mother oh wow
he was adopted as well
so we were connected but but neither of
us knew our birth
parents okay and uh at any rate
his situation wasn't like mine he had
some difficulties in his journey
that he shares freely i can share that
without feeling like i'm betraying the
confidence
and um at any rate i posted a picture of
us
on a site called dna detectives got
hundreds of thousands of uh
people and their search angels that help
you reunite with your birth family wow
they had
several thousand uh likes and and i was
like wow you know this is awesome you
know this is what these people do and
but someone reached out to me several
people reach out but one person stood
out in particular
and she said with the information you
have
and and and knowing that this who this
cousin is
i can find your birth mother and i can
find her tonight whoa
wow and i was like oh and these people
aren't asking for any money or no
no a search angel angels never ask for
money praise god for
you know people like this in our world
that just want to i mean that's what
everybody's life should be about right
how can i bless somebody else
what can i do for somebody else what a
beauty she didn't even like thank you
she and she's just like listen i just
want you to go forward you know just
find her and she helped me manage
expectations you know this is what
happens sometimes people are excited at
first and then they talk to their family
then they tell you don't contact them
sometimes people just have a one-time
reunion
and that's it and she helped me manage
that really well basically she's like
john
expect nothing yeah and that way if you
get something is better but if you get
nothing at least you were ready for it
wow
and um so she about to i was speaking
virtually in the cayman islands and
i spoke and she actually tuned into my
message and she's like oh you know my
father was a preacher
and she was in charlotte and she was
like you know i live in i was like oh i
got married in charlotte
and i just knew this was the right
person but i wasn't confident she would
find my birth mother i didn't know if my
birth mother would be alive
i didn't know if she would want to deal
with me or talk to me right
and um so about 12 hours later
in the morning i woke up overnight she i
got a message from this search angel her
name's amy
and she said this is her and she said
the only the only way this is not her
is if she has a sister that's the same
age as her
who got pregnant and gave up a child for
adoption at the same exact time and
that's the only way this is not your
mother
and she said but to be to be certain i
need her mother's maiden name
so reach out to her i was like no you
reach out here and she's like no you
reach out to her and i was like no go
ahead she's like oh you go ahead
and so i did i i kind of had to build up
you know how you like right
i can do this for sure so i psyched
myself up
and i sent a message and i said hey i'm
trying to put together a family tree
and i have a search angel researcher
helping me
and i need to know your mother's maiden
name i know this is strange
but this is who i am this you can google
me and
uh if you gave me this it'd be very
helpful were you were you sweating to
push the send button just like
no you know what i psyched myself up all
day i waited until like midnight that
night
well i was like i'm going to sleep soon
and just you know yeah i got it that
morning
from what i can recall in my messages
wow yeah
and when i got up i had a response so
immediately did you know
now you know there's so much scam and
things like that
on social media you know and i didn't
know i'm thinking
wait a minute i thought i thought the
worst at first and i did for a little
while
and i thought well wait a minute he's
got information here
right that why does he need my mother's
name and then
i proceeded to tell him i said look i
need to know who this is i said i
lost a son he then turned around and
said what do you mean you lost a son
well you said how do you think we're
connected yeah and i didn't want to say
i think you're my mom so i said well if
i had that out no and then she said well
i lost the son and i
said well what do you mean you lost a
son and i told him i said i had to give
a child up to protect him
he started going over his birthday
in that place my emotion so yeah your
heart is probably racist
i couldn't even talk i i i had taken my
mother to the doctor
i said look i need some time my emotions
were
uncomprehensible it was just you
couldn't explain it
and i called my his brother
um first and i said i think
my son has reached out to me oh wow this
is amazing because when we hear
stories like this it's usually from the
child's perspective you know looking out
and
trying to find their birth parent
imagine the shock of the parent like
whoa
yeah yeah and now you're on my doorstep
like the emotions that come with that
yeah it may have been 38 years
38 years so i feel like we need a back
story on what was going on in your life
because we don't know that yet i'm
curious like
yes you get this message were you
expecting a message where you
i had prayed from them
from the time i let john go when i
carried him
from the delivery room
i held him i knew because of the
background
how did you do it do you mind sharing
how you decided i decided
what i needed to do because in my third
trimester
i was in a very bad abusive relationship
and the man that i was with tried to
make me lose
john and i knew at that point in my
third trimester
that by the time he was born i would
have to do something
but what as i get closer and closer i
just kept getting nudged toward
letting go to adoption i didn't believe
in
abortion or anything like that and um
so i let him go with a kiss and a prayer
it was that prayer that i've held on to
for 38 years
through god's grace that i would get to
meet him
and see him before i pass this world wow
and it was god's grace that brought him
to me wow
so i let him go but he was brought back
and we serve a god of answered prayers
you know what i mean you pray and it's
amazing that
that he and his timing works that out
you know
yes yeah i was uh i you know hearing the
story for mom i thought about this verse
in psalms 94
for a thousand years in thy sight or but
as yesterday when it has passed and it's
like a watch in the night
wow and 38 years seemed like forever but
i tell you
in in the video the mini doc that uh was
that was that was sharing
that uh in the scene in the moment that
we talked
i forgot the 38 years wow it meant
nothing anymore
it was just like an instant yeah let me
tell you how john came about
the um i call him the evil one
and um i was separated from him for a
short time and i got raped
and um i knew he would be a mixed baby i
didn't have a problem with that it had
nothing to do with racism
it had nothing to do with rejection it
was all in a matter of protecting him
and making sure that he was never hurt
by
anyone near me
so you made the you know mom the first
time we talked
she asked me to forgive her all right
yeah what's the first thing i asked i
didn't
i had a lot of feelings i didn't know
what to i still don't know what to feel
but the only one i'm clear on is
gratitude
because when she shared with me that i'm
a product of rape wow and she shared
with me that the man she was with
in a relationship was abusive
and beat her in her third trimester with
me to try to kill me wow
and when she shared that she had to give
me up to give me safe passage
i and and knowing the family i was
raised in i
i'm i'm grateful i have brought i'm
grateful to his family because in my
eyes
god knew when i had to let him go that
he
already had a family picked out for him
and i'm most thankful to
the family he has you know even though
i'm his biological mother
i'm grateful for his family wow
yeah we get a lot of comments from
people you know when when the topic of
abortion comes up you know it's always
like
well i think it you know there's times
that you should be able to do it rape
and all these things but think about
this
i mean you're a pastor you were a pastor
like
if your mother would have decided to
abort you that's one person who led
multiple people to the lord who wouldn't
have come about 42 countries
i mean the fact that you have had this
kind of influence over
so many people is is just adds such a
beauty to this story
because it's like you know here think of
all the people that that would have been
robbed of a blessing
had had you just like you know not made
it through that
and so you know this is a testament of
truly you know god can take a situation
like that
he can turn it around for his glory and
and
you know what a beautiful thing and this
is not the end of our
journey i don't have 38 years left
or i can't make that up so this is only
the beginning of our journey
as a family together from our end you
know what's so beautiful when i think of
like the resurrection day
that the angels will personally carry
the babies to their mothers
and and that just interaction that's
going to happen between people i mean
you know i can only imagine a a mother
like my wife has a different connection
with my children than i do
you can see there's this bond there
there that is just
it's it's on a different level it's just
different and and that never goes away
even though you had what days with him
maybe
you know how not even hours not even
and i mean he was it was a quick labor
and
and no sooner than i had him and they
bundled him up and they had us on the
bed and i was holding him and
when we got to our room and i gave him
that kiss and that prayer that was it
was last time i saw him can i can i ask
and you don't have to answer this if you
don't want to
what was what was going on in your
emotions in your heart
after you went home from that hospital
and the days afterwards
i recently just told john this you know
it was i know a good week or two
after i let him go that i wanted to go
back and get him
and just run as far as i could but i
wasn't able to
uh within that first week i was just
mourning so bad
but when i get home the next day i was
immediately raped again by the man that
was back i was back with
wow so it's a lot to the story
but in my eyes john god knew
what he was preparing for my son so
and i guess maybe that's why he i know
guests know
he had already decided where john was
going to do
and be and how he was going to live and
i'm so grateful
that he's a man of god isn't that neat
that god has plans for us to prosper
he has plans for us that we don't we
don't even know but he's right he sees
it he's knitting us together in the womb
and he's already thought i'm ordaining
this guy right here for this job to work
in my fields
and to win people for me i'm so graced
and blessed
and mainly grace that god has allowed
me to have time with him and his family
i've got a beautiful daughter-in-law
a beautiful nine-year-old granddaughter
i mean it's just amazing
you think about how one life produces
just more lives and just keeps going
right
you we did on on this show um as i was
kind of sharing with you guys before we
started here um when the movie unplanned
came out
you know which really tackles this this
topic of abortion
the one thing that we hear over and over
and over again that young people always
say no matter what circle you bring this
up in
consider conservative liberal doesn't
matter they always bring up the rape
component
if if i was raped then then it's okay
you know you have a license to go and
and and take care of that life
right but you know it's amazing that
that
even hollywood and all those they put
that r rating on there and they didn't
want people at that age range
between 13 to 17 to actually go and see
that movie because i believe that that's
that age range is where people make a
decision what's going to happen
if you get into a situation like that
that you can't control
that that that happened to you what what
are you going to do with it moving
forward
and i think any time we sit down and we
say lord this is outside of me
you are the one that that has to take
this life
and and and i'm dedicating him to you
and that prayer that you prayed lord i
just want to see him before i mean god
god god made good on that promise he did
and it was all in his time you know
there was um
uh i went to unsolved mysteries and
another
company to try to find him and two
siblings that are missing
and i i was i was blocked and all that
and i i did not know about ancestry dna
because that's just now come out in my
time so you were basically looking as
well
yeah i just never looked i didn't know
ancestry dna basically the bottom line
right right
yeah i'm so curious about this like how
do they know
when they get the paperwork back for
this because i've never done it before
is it basically say
you were born in this area this region
poor ancestry
yeah no it just gives you it measures uh
centimorgans the number of
points that you're connected in shared
dna okay and um
it'll let you any you someone who would
have had to be a part of that database
so
submit their dna to that database and
that's a you connect and
um and so a parent-child relationship
is all the way on the highest end
basically
and uh over 3000 connection points 3
300 something like that and um and so
mom and i we we did the dna test but
we knew we were yeah we knew we knew
yeah before that and the only reason i
went ahead and done
my end of a dna test was for the
formality of it
that was the bottom line so it let you
know it was immediately
already coming back no not a question no
no no more questions okay so so we're
at this point right here right you now
know this is your son
what happens next oh we we move on
he flies me tries to fly me and run me
all over the country i said i wouldn't
go to
no more airports without tennis shoes or
sandals
she could wear her boots
so as you guys are are deciding to meet
for the first time um
i in the video that you guys produced
was really amazing how it was kind of
showing your story and your story
interconnecting together and how it was
getting closer and closer to the point
where you see them converge
i thought that was a well-done piece
yeah he did a really good job um
what what was that like when you were
when you were walking out
yeah when you were walking up or knowing
the day that you were going to meet this
this this person that is connected to
you for me we had we had been speaking
for
a couple of weeks yeah and we finally we
were trying to wait out the pandemic and
we finally said well
you know let's just go for it and so we
just couldn't wait anymore
and uh i we drove my wife and i and our
daughter
we drove for seven hours because it was
the best place to meet
and it just happened to be in the place
mom was born in
and um and so we drove there and
um we were into the place and got you
know she got my grandmother who's still
alive to come and
her husband of 21 years as a matter of
fact you know one of the
most touching moments of the entire
reunion was the day after we talked on
the phone for the first time
her husband called me dwayne and he said
i just want you to know
that the very first date i had with your
mother
she told me she had a son and one day
you guys were going to be reunited
no i had never been denied yeah as i was
going to say he has never been denied
anybody that
i was with prior to my husband of 21
years
and my husband of 21 years knew you know
look i've got an older son and i'm
hoping one day
that he'll come back into my life and
his brother brothers sister
cousins aunties uncles everybody in the
family knew about him
wow they just didn't i don't think they
expected
everything to come to play the way it
did yeah but i was
we were always close to each other my
grandmother lived
uh not far from my family in florida
my mom and and her husband uh i call him
dad
you know he welcomes it i'm happy it's
no problem for me
and uh they were living they had their
his home
was uh an hour and 15 minutes from where
i went to undergraduate
college and and so all we were passing i
had aunts
in in one city i pastored and cousins in
another city i passed it in
and all of us were always near each
other
it just wasn't the right time it wasn't
god's time it was never god's time until
it was
so in that so in that moment driving up
i think i was the night before i didn't
sleep i'm not a big caffeine drinker so
i was like i drove i didn't sleep and
drove for seven hours on
sheer excitement and adrenaline and
and uh anxiety and uh when we got close
we uh got there and in that moment
i i tell you in when we hugged for the
first time
it somehow and i i hate to
make it more magical than it is it's not
it's spiritual
it's real spirituality is real magic is
not it is yeah
i i could hear god's without a
relationship with god i love him he's my
father
and and i am grateful for his love in my
life
and um like i said the 38 years prior
meant nothing
and in that moment i could i could hear
god
say i allowed you to to go through what
you went through so that you would know
i always had your story in my hands and
i can only imagine if
mom decided to put my light out and i
think i had people i've had
uh maybe set i think 72 people the last
time i looked
72 individual people from different
parts of the world
and said you know i gave my life to
christ because of you in africa
because of you in europe south america
and i saw your story
and i can't imagine if your mom had
given up i wouldn't be a christian
and my husband or my wife my children
wouldn't be christians my neighbors and
so
i think i think he allowed me to carry
the rejection and not know the full
story because when the
when the right moment came he wanted me
to know that it meant nothing
in the full grand scheme of things it
doesn't feel like that when you're
hurting
right it doesn't feel like that when
you're when you have anxiety or when
you're depressed
you feel like that moment is everything
yeah but it is a moment and it will pass
there's so many stories in the bible
like as you're talking i'm thinking of
joseph you know what i mean rejected by
his brother
sold kicked down put into prison and
that guy has every right to be angry
upset at god what's up dude i'm i'm
following you
and look at what you've done to my life
and he still served him just
unconditionally and and and just love
god
and also i i can't help but to think of
like god
how he feels when he was separated from
his son
sure and that you know i thought about
that same same thing and i'm thinking
lord
how did you do it god how how did you
handle that i you know
with everything that god has been doing
it's just
no way for us to comprehend because
letting john go
is a deep heart it's a very deep hurt
but i knew that god
he understands that yeah he understands
that because we often talk about the
suffering
that jesus did and no doubt he went
through in immense
suffering but the heart of god has the
power to stop it
and doesn't and and has to shield
himself from it and you think like okay
you know i have this conversation with
my kids all the time about god's omni
or god's forever been right and they're
always like i don't understand that
right
so no time has god ever been separated
from his son
and those three days must have been so
excruciating
yeah and and so i think god takes
pleasure
in seeing a couple you know uh family
members like this that get reunited
together
i think it's it speaks to the heart of
god speaks
especially when they're spiritual
spirituality and god is foremost
in the situation it speaks out to more
yeah yeah and i get i and you you know
you asked about
the feelings just and i don't i know mom
you didn't
share what were you feeling as you knew
that moment was coming as the day got
close
yeah i couldn't explain the emotions my
husband's got a video of me facing back
and forth and i was like
man how much longer they gonna keep him
and they had him like 45 more minutes
and
i'm thinking lord how do i put all these
words all these feelings into words
there's just
just you can't you just cannot oh man
when we hugged for the first time it was
um
i don't know if you've ever made
anything and when you finish it
you're like this is it you know yeah and
in that moment i
i don't know i just felt this great
sense of accomplishment
greater really then the only other time
i felt that way
was when my daughter was born and and so
when she said you know your mind she
helped me and she whispered in my you're
my son
and i this the last time i held you was
when i let you go in the hospital
and in that moment just this this flood
of
of uh of of god's presence was just
there
and like i had you the whole time
it's okay you can let this go now that's
other question because
your experience is is very different
than a lot of experiences some others
that i've heard i know a young man he
was adopted
talked to him about it and you know i've
asked him
have you wanted to reconnect
with your biological parents and his
response was
no not really yeah yeah he was
adopted by a very loving family has a
great support system and i'm wondering
when you were contemplating all this did
you ever go through these thoughts of
how would my life be different because
you think about if you have
more family it's like well how do i
split my holidays and
yeah you know am i gonna call that
person mom or am i gonna call that
person dad or you know what i mean
there's
did you go through thinking through some
of that
as you were contemplating your situation
um i think i didn't um i didn't like we
this is
this trip today being here this is the
fourth time we've seen each other in our
lives
wow and uh we talk every day and we talk
on duo
and um but um i i don't
i don't know that i considered what that
would look like i knew i wanted to have
a relationship i didn't know what it
would look like
and i didn't know my story i didn't know
my mother was raped and
in an abusive relationship and had i
didn't know those details
and so i wouldn't i didn't i didn't have
an idea of what i wanted
i think once we connected i have still
not considered i i tell you one thing
that that was very refreshing we live in
a
very racially charged time and my family
is is a good tennessee white good
mississippi white
you know good southern white folk you
know and
but but man we've not talked about race
one time right wow i wasn't beautiful
they were not white i was not black in
this instance i don't like when people
say i don't see color because you can
you gotta be blind not to yeah but but i
will say
being in in just we were just family
sitting on the porch drinking sweet tea
and you know
my daughter shooting guns with her uncle
and ryan
it was beautiful the most precious
things going back to your question is um
you know is he going to call me mom or
is he going to call me by my name or
i miss simmons or anything like that but
the most precious thing
to me is after we met
it wasn't none of that it was just mom
and i just cried for like the first two
weeks because i was like
he calls me mom yeah you know so i mean
it was just
it was that immediate connection
you brought up joseph i was thinking of
moses you know
moses was going to be killed if the mom
didn't do something yeah and put in the
basket and look how god used moses in
such a great way to free people and
bring people to the lord yeah
no it's i it's been just a flood of uh
experience and i love to share and i
don't know i guess when you're living it
you don't know how powerful it is or
like people are like oh my you know i
was telling some lady in the grocery
store she just started crying and
then she closed her lane and the manager
came over and the manager started crying
and i was like and i started crying and
i hope that people think they're crazy
and not me
but it was um i don't know i guess it's
like
the gospel when you come in contact with
something good you just want to tell
people
and that's been really cathartic for me
just telling people telling people on
the planet i
told one i was flying in somewhere and
my cousin
who uh helped all of this come together
in a sense because
he connected with me we went together to
new york
and he found his birth mother wow and he
didn't go over as well
it was a little different okay but but
it did go it was
it was good for him he managed that way
it was nice
i thought it was beautiful yeah and um i
guess he was in it so it's a little
different for him
but um then my brother who has not seen
his biological daughter
my biological brother my younger brother
for 14 years
and she's 16 now he reconnected with her
wow
and so it's been a lot of uh beautiful
connections
as a result of it it's just god's time
and i'm okay with that
yeah when it comes to the details of
things we could really like
freak ourselves out yeah yeah and how it
happens with a lot of things it's good
to be prepared to think things through
but when you're actually in the moment
things just
work themselves in such a beautiful way
and that's what i think is so fantastic
while being a christian with having that
connection with christ because he takes
care of the details
as soon as you met yeah but we still get
lost in the details we still have
questions we still have doubts at times
the stronger you grow your faith though
the stronger
those things go away yeah yep that's
true
yeah i was even thinking like how you
shared the story with
someone in the checkout line and the you
don't even know if those people are
christian or not
this is a story that can touch people's
lives without that wall of oh
christianity or whatever
but they might get so touched and be
like well what why did you make these
decisions why didn't you just abort
well because i'm a christian and now
they are like
wow you know all this happened because
of your
your um beliefs and stuff you know it's
a good way to share the guys i do the
same thing i mean
everywhere i go i'm still raising
children and i go to the orthodontist or
a dentist or
a doctor's appointment and i see
somebody and i'm like
lord can i share there and then he'll
nudge me and i share it the same way
i'll
i'll go up to complete strangers hey you
want to hear a story you know it's not a
it's not about religion or not it's
about god's grace we went to a
restaurant together once just two of us
and she's like hey guys this is myself
i'm proud of him i thank god for it
that was really nice i mean it's really
neat to see even you guys interaction
because
i mean even just observing how you guys
have been since the second you got here
it's
it's a beautiful thing i mean there's
there is a a
a a warmness about your relationship now
and this is your fourth time
hanging out he loves me too yeah already
got me
yeah my little brother opened the hotel
last night and closed the door i was
like
he went down the hall i don't know where
he is i'm going to go get that boy let
me just jump
to bed after that that was too far and
that's another thing amazing about god
is because
i have emotions that i've been dealing
with where you know
should i be jealous you know am i
jealous that that
this family that was so loving that god
provided for
him you know from a mother's perspective
i still deal with some emotions that i
put in god's hand because
i'm still seeing i'm still i'm not
raising him but
i'm still there growing with him still
so yeah there's a lot there's a lot to
the story there's a lot going on
i do have a question like if you have
any advice
for for mothers out there who are put in
the situation of having to give up their
child
how to maybe work through that
especially in the first few years that's
probably the most difficult
yeah because there wasn't uh the first
five years you know i was thinking about
this the other night and i told john a
little bit but
you know that first birthday you missed
that first birthday and
you know i wanted to light a candle and
in each like every fifth year and then
when he became a teenager and
you know and you know those things are
they're impactful they're very impactful
but when you
put it and i'm not gonna say it's easy
to say okay god here's my emotions and
feelings and
and that's it you know you just you have
to
really get down hard to let god have
all of these emotions that you're
dealing with and not
give up no i'll say i i've i've not been
a mother
and i have no idea what it would be like
i can't even imagine but i certainly
would say that if my mother my
biological mother had decided
that she were going to abort me that
not only would my light have been put
out but the the beautiful lights of
all of the people that i've seen uh the
lives and the
the the journeys that they've taken that
those would have not
intersected in the way that they did and
so i would say
on behalf of every child who comes from
a difficult or uncertain situation give
give that child a chance because your
difficulty
in that decision to allow them to be
adopted could be
their safe passage forward and it might
take 38 years like it did with my mother
or not
but it was worth it it was worth it
amen wow anything else you guys want to
share about
you know kind of where you're going now
we're just going to continue on the
journey that god has placed us on and
hope that we can hold on
and we've been reconnecting in different
places we went to the my
undergraduate college yeah where i i'm
doing my doctoral program i'm a
professor now and
um so she got to see my office and where
i studied and i got to go back to
where he uh his parents went and were
supportive of him and
going to college in huntsville alabama
yeah and
and i know they've got their enjoyment
with their pictures and everything you
guys see my name on the stomach
he allowed me to get some pictures with
him you know to share in that joy with
them
yeah as well so i mean it's just it's a
very special journey
journey relationship that god has placed
to senate i'm not going to let go as
long as he don't let go
yeah and then if you let scale on my
whooping machine yeah yeah the only the
only thing
that you know how dna is like 99.99
there's only like one tenth of a percent
that makes me like not sure she's still
a little skeptical
i'm like i don't know if i came from you
if you're doing this
i do have two questions the first one is
as some as
someone who has found out that they're
adopted do you have any advice
for them if they're in that decision of
should i reach out or how do i feel
about myself
now that i found out that i'm adopted my
my world has now shifted
sure well i i will say your identity is
not your past
and your identity is not where you come
from that's a part of
who you are it's not who you are and i
certainly would say
don't carry the sense of rejection and
exercise rebellion because of it
the the safest place and i have this
verse here in psalms 91 verse 1 he that
dwelleth in the secret place of the most
high
shall abide under the shadow of the
almighty the safest place
for you to to abide or dwell with all of
those feelings
is in god's presence in his hands in his
care and so you find yourself in a very
dangerous
place when you feel the overwhelming
tide of rejection because you were
adopted
and you take that journey without christ
and so take it with him
that's my first bit of advice my second
bit of advice is that
i um i had a very supportive family and
my family while they may not have
understood what was happening
internally they they gave me the support
and nurture i needed to thrive
and that may or may not be your
scenario but what i will say is that
don't expect people to understand what
you feel because even with
all of the love and support i still felt
that there was something more i wanted
to know and um
and and that's valid and it's valuable
and um
if someone doesn't understand when you
try to explain it it's not because
your your experience is invalid it is
simply because they have not had that
experience
so take it with christ and own who you
are
and uh be okay with what the future
holds because god holds the future
powerful the second question was um the
next step
forward someone who has decided okay i
do want to reconnect
you talked about some resources that you
used just asking if you could
share what those were and those who are
interested
absolutely i used uh at home dna kits i
did
uh three of them and uh you can do two
and just share your raw data and and so
i won't
give a plug because they're not paying
me to give a plug but you just find an
at-home
dna kit and and uh with that
the manager expectations my expectations
were like way up here
and it shouldn't have been that high i
thought it would just immediately
let me know and it doesn't work that way
but when you do it you will find
connections the database is large enough
you're talking about millions of people
that have shared this dna and if you
want to close that
that gap that's a great place to start i
will share a group
because they were so helpful to me
absolutely free
and they use social media they use
facebook it's called dna
detectives and welcoming community
very affirming they don't allow any
negative banter i've heard some very
strange stories
but they're very supportive and if you
uh they have thousands
i think about 100 500 000 members in the
group
and if you want to share your story
there it's very
likely someone may reach out in hell i
might be your search angel one day
because i hope to help somebody do what
somebody helped me do
and i'm still learning so i can't help
well what a beautiful beautiful
testimony you guys to
come and bless us with i mean just i i
look forward to even hearing how this
relationship is gonna going to move
forward from here i'm already looking
for our first christmas
that's the first year you know yeah i
mean yeah
i want to mention this one thing i had
had actually multiple people in my life
that i've met
that have lost a child whether it be
they died or were in a car accident or
something
and i'm always very curious um you know
to know
well you know what is that pain like and
they described
losing a child is there's no pain like
that
and and like you said it's hard for me
to fathom because i i don't i'm not
there i i've never experienced that so
it's hard for me to even wrap my head
around it but um
one interesting thing that one of the
the guys that uh lost his daughter when
she was 18 years old she just had an
aneurysm and passed away in the morning
on on
before on the way to school he said as
much pain as there is
god opens a door for love and it's like
the deeper the pain the deeper the
ability to experience
love to me that's god's way of really
um um balancing out you know what i mean
you've had a
painful beginning yeah and so now the
the every little moment is so precious
for you
that you're gonna enjoy it that the
taste of it is so much
grander you know what i mean and so
moving forward i i think it's really
neat
please you know enjoy every moment and
those family times that that you know
you get a chance to build memories
you you you have a chance to build more
memories down the road
and and even into eternity so
thank you for coming on our show you
guys got any other questions
i'm so grateful for what you do yeah and
you have been a blessing to my journey
and i know and to mine and i'm sure to
three more back then praise god i praise
god
well tell us a little bit about your
ministry as well because if any of you
are watching out there i mean
if you've traveled around and and even
shared the gospel in this way
and you want him to come and speak at
your church how can they get in
contact with you and you can follow me
at uh on facebook on my fan page john t
boston ii that's roman numeral 2 or iii
also on instagram i um i lecture and
teach around the world i focus on
helping people overcoming trauma
and live successful lives and rise above
their pain and so
i'd love to support your journey and i
love to hear your story so do follow me
and also
this video is coming out friday or in a
couple of days i'm not sure when this
will be seen
but i want you to see that the story of
our re reunion
and their details that weren't shared
here that are shared on that video
well thank you guys for tuning in and uh
we hope that you were as
blessed as we were i know i definitely
enjoyed this conversation completely
and um keep us in your prayers keep them
in your prayers keep
other people that you may know are going
through this exact same experience
and um you know this this is the
struggle of life that we're all engaged
in
but god has our best interest at heart
and
and if we put our trust in him and we
stay connected to him
god will not let us down he is the god
of of of wanting us to experience
um joy and and pleasure and things in
our lives so
put your trust in god uh we hope that
you guys had a blessed time
like this video share this video maybe
this is something that somebody else
needs to hear
please forward it and uh we hope to see
you guys
next friday on led live
[Music]
you